bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
ex presidente alberto fujimori es
probablemente la figura política peruana
más controversial de las últimas décadas
el ex mandatario es amado y odiado por
los peruanos y la reciente aprobación
del tribunal constitucional de este país
para sacarlo de prisión ha vuelto a
encender la llama de la polémica
crímenes de lesa humanidad autoritarismo
o corrupción son algunos de los
escándalos que marcaron su gobierno
entre el año 1990 y el 2000
alberto fujimori llegó al poder en un
momento crítico para perú para finales
de la década de 1980 el país andino
sufría una de las hiperinflaciones más
elevadas del planeta y estaba envuelto
desde hacía décadas en un conflicto
armado contra la guerrilla maoísta
sendero luminoso que había dejado
decenas de miles de víctimas una crisis
que este ingeniero de ascendencia
japonesa supo aprovechar postulándose
como un candidato diferente a los
partidos tradicionales de perú su
principal reto a su llegada a la
presidencia fue mejorar la situación
económica peruana con una política
neoliberal comenzó a privatizar empresas
clave del sector público para atraer
inversión extranjera y logró reducir la
hiperinflación que azotaba al país desde
hacía años
estos resultados elevaron su popularidad
entre la población el otro punto fuerte
de sus políticas de gobierno fue la
lucha contra el terrorismo fujimori
endureció el combate contra sendero
luminoso y el movimiento revolucionario
túpac amaru con el objetivo de terminar
con su influencia una postura dura que
se refleja en casos como la intervención
tras la toma de la embajada japonesa en
1997 por el movimiento tupac amaru en la
que los 14 terroristas fueron asesinados
sin embargo esta política también alentó
la financiación y el apoyo a grupos
paramilitares que operaban como
escuadrones de la muerte contra todo
civil sobre el que hubiera una sospecha
de colaboración con la guerrilla
algunas de estas acciones fueron actos
de violencia indiscriminados contra la
población civil
el 3 de noviembre de 1991 se produjo la
masacre de barrios altos en la que
fueron asesinadas 15 personas que
estaban en una reunión vecinal y en
julio de 1992 nueve alumnos y un
profesor universitario fueron asesinados
en la cantuta por tener supuestos nexos
con sendero luminoso no vamos a permitir
que terroristas que han matado que han
reflexionado han cometido atentados en
contra del pueblo y en contra del país
se han liberado
berta liberación amigos desde un
comienzo alberto fujimori mostró tener
un carácter con tendencia al
autoritarismo algo que se confirmó en
1992 el 5 de abril de ese año el
mandatario se dio un auto golpe de
estado en el que con ayuda del ejército
se tomó el congreso y las sedes
judiciales fujimori no controlaba el
órgano legislativo y sus leyes eran
constantemente bloqueadas algo que
sirvió como pretexto para esta
intervención aprovechando el descrédito
que sufría la política tradicional
tras el fujimorato su poder aumentó y
fue reelegido en
1995 su segundo mandato comenzó con un
plan de salud pública que fomentó la
esterilización entre mujeres de bajos
recursos con el objetivo de frenar la
pobreza en el país una medida polémica
que lo fue más cuando se empezaron a
denunciar esterilizaciones forzadas en
condiciones infrahumanas a mujeres
indígenas y pobres de áreas
especialmente rurales los datos son
contradictorios pero se estima que
durante su gobierno se esterilizaron
alrededor de unas 350.000 mujeres y 25
mil hombres
todavía está por determinar el número de
esterilizaciones que fueron forzadas sin
embargo ninguna de las polémicas
mencionadas consiguió tumbar al
presidente fujimori entre denuncias de
fraude electoral fue reelegido para un
tercer mandato en el año 2000 todo
indicaba que aún quedaban cinco años más
de fujimorismo por delante hasta que a
los pocos meses salieron a la luz vídeos
en los que se veía a gente del círculo
íntimo de fujimori sobornar a políticos
y empresarios la privatización de
empresas de años anteriores fue de la
mano junto con un clientelismo y
corrupción que enriqueció a fujimori ya
su entorno durante una década y esto sí
que terminó con su gobierno el 19 de
noviembre emitió un fax de renuncia
desde tokio y se refugió en japón para
no ser perseguido por las autoridades su
exilio en japón levantó mucha polémica
pero en 2005 fue detenido en santiago de
chile durante un viaje tras una orden de
arresto internacional este fue el inicio
de su periplo carcelario en septiembre
de 2007 fue extraditado a perú y
comenzaron juicios e investigaciones en
su contra fujimori tuvo enjuiciamientos
por allanamiento de morada corrupción y
robo de fondos públicos aunque la
condena más importante de todas fue por
crímenes de lesa humanidad por las
masacres en barrios altos y la cantuta
y morí entró en prisión con la
perspectiva probable de pasar allí el
resto de su vida pero no fue así desde
el inicio de su condena el sector
político fujimorista encabezado por su
hija keiko pidió su indulto humanitario
por su progresivo deterioro físico y su
avanzada edad peticiones que fueron
desoídas hasta que en 2017 el ex
presidente pedro pablo kuczynski decidió
ponerlo en libertad una medida polémica
que tumbó la justicia devolviendo la
prisión en 2019 tres años después el
indulto parece volver a hacerse efectivo
a pesar de la controversia que implica y
de que fujimori siga teniendo casos
pendientes en su contra una situación
que puede contribuir a la ya volátil
crisis política que sufre perú desde
con esto concluimos gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]